[Music]
what is Godzilla doing in the series
Monarch the legacy of monsters so this
video we explain what has happened
currently as of the Eight Episodes
regarding this series and what is in
store for us in the last two that will
be aired starting next year let's get to
it so to get to the bottom of it all we
have to first take a look at what has
happened as of now in the series in
short in 2015 a year after gday the Rand
kids are searching for their father hero
Shanda and at the same time are thrown
into a struggle between Monarch and his
agents against Shaw and his own team of
Rogue operatives Monarch who wants to
study and contain the Titan threats that
are emerging at an alarming rate while
leaw wants another thing to completely
seal off the hollow Earth Bortles and in
turn thinks he is helping Godzilla well
as well as redeeming deing his loss of
giko Randa who was dragged into one of
these by the endos Swarm creatures that
hatch way back in
1959 Mona thinks Lee Shaw's actions are
causing a series of chain reactions that
is counterintuitive in that they are
causing other Hollow Earth portles to
spring up in frequency and increase in
radiation output which might lead to
another mut or Titan emergence event
which they are trying desperately to
prevent sure on the other hand thinks
Monarch is just laed and not at all
active but just reacting passively to
the Titans which is why he has to take
action by himself the show also takes us
back in time to the 1950s where the
three that is Bill Randa Kiko mura and
leaw are creating the elusive Titan
monitoring organization Monarch in these
years they have together encountered
Godzilla a couple of times including in
bikini ATL where the US military tried
to kill him which failed they tried to
kill him with a thermonuclear weapon The
Castle Bravo which was un successful as
they again encountered the Gman in
Monster Island near the Japanese
archipelago a couple of years later
along the road to securing Monarch as a
proper agency they also encountered
other deadly Titans including the
juvenile Iron Dragon in the Philippines
which was in fact their first day
together and then in 1959 they came face
to face with the endos Swarm creatures
which caused the life of Dr mura in the
end these two timelines are starting to
make sense in the later episodes in a
fine way of Storytelling which is
beginning to conclude in them tackling a
serious world-ending threat that is 50
years in the making so now that we are
up to date with the story line let's
come back to Godzilla and discuss what
he was doing in Algeria what is his
primary role in the series as well as in
the monsterverse as a whole and end with
the overarching threat in the series
okay Godzilla was seen to appear in 1954
firstly in the Bikini atos
chronologically that is where he was
lured and blasted with a thermonuclear
bomb the Castle Bravo
this was first of all a reboot of the
timeline a soft reboot where the
shinomura is now essentially
non-existent in that Universe in this
first chronological sighting he was
slightly different as he was Slimmer and
smaller with shorter dorsal plates and
then after the nuke a couple of years
later he was led by the gamma radiation
in Monster Island and when he appeared
there he seems to have grown bigger with
more prominent dosal identical to the
2014 OG design this shows that the nuke
is in fact a helpful thing it fed him
with a lot of radiation that pushed him
to grow and evolve into the next stage
Godzilla's next form was again seen in
Algeria in 2015 where he emerged out of
the ground where he was resting on and
here he seems to have evolved into the
kotm design again pushed by something
unexplained as of yet uh you know to
evolve and grow it could be the mut
Prime the battle between him and the mut
Prime but it could be something else as
well as this series is kind of a soft
reboot to the comics as well so what was
he doing in Algeria and how did he get
there it was all that Godzilla
disappeared into the Pacific Ocean of
the San Francisco battle in 2014 only to
reappear in 2015 a year later in
Northern Africa in a location of the
Sahara desert in Algeria he seems to
have been hibernating or resting there
for quite a while as the ground on top
of him looks to be firm and stable to a
point where none of the people on top of
him the rander kids or even Lee Shaw
noticed that they in fact on top of him
when he awakened it was clear that he
was a bit changed having the kotm design
with the dosel plac to a maple leaf in
shape and then after a roar he walked
away slowly only to disappear again but
this was later explained vaguely in the
series that Godzilla went into one of
the hollow Earth portals sort of a
Vortex Wormhole that allowed the tirans
to navigate in and out of the hollow
Earth to reappear again in the surface
World thousands of miles away from their
original position
this thing was first described in Skull
Island in 2017 the movie which was
chronologically in 1973 and then
observed during king of the monsters
when Godzilla went into one of these off
the coast of South America to speed up
travel and reach Antarctica in a matter
of hours to combat Monster Zero so
Godzilla uses these frequently and even
the other Titans do it on a less scale
though so as you will see in the later
episodes okay now that we know what Goa
was doing in Algeria and how did he get
there let's dive into what his primary
role in the series and in the most verse
is so we know for a fact that he is an
alpha Titan and an apex predator as
described in the previous movies we also
know that Monarch classifies him as a
protected Titan and we do know from low
that he came from the hollow Earth he
was engaged in a Titan war against the
Kongs and that he also had his own human
followers who worshiped and created a
domain for him as seen in the ruins of
his layer in kotm
now in the series leaw who has had a
long 50e standing one-sided relationship
with Godzilla knows more about the
Titan's motives more than anyone else
including the Monarch organization he
states that Godzilla exists on earth to
regulate the Titan emergences and to
drive them back to their Hollow Earth
realm to separate the human world with
the Monster World this can be
corroborated with the g man's actions in
setting the Titans back into hibernation
at the end of kotm and also his con
patrolling of the world's oceans to
drive back the Titans that do come out
onto the surface which explains his
aggressive attitude towards Kong gidora
Mecha Godzilla Mark yuger and also the
mutos now lastly what is the main
overarching threat in the series and is
there a powerful tatter that will battle
with Godzilla in the end you know a
classic monster Showdown that would be
the climax to all this
forl so for the first question the main
threat that is looming about in The
Horizon is a Titan emergence event that
would be caused by the actions of Lee
Shaw in such an event Monarch fears the
appearance of Titans like the mutos that
would cause widespread destruction to
the human world such a thing would
plunge the entire planet into a state of
chaos and Anarchy and not to mention the
untold loss of lives Imagine The Hollow
Earth Titans like the war bats and Chas
appearing out of nowhere on a massive
scale along with the serious Titans like
the Iron Dragon who has mysteriously
disappeared in the 1950s presumably into
one of these portals so that brings us
to the final point that is will Godzilla
Battle another Titan in the series as we
have seen in the midseason trailer The
Iron Dragon would be pitched in a one a
one-on-one battle against the Gman the
top G amidst a landscape filled with
emergence points and in this case it
won't be a juvenile Dragon but a massive
adult specimen similar in size to a male
Muto of 2014 but you know with different
powers so that particular battle is
assured and yeah Goda might have to f
off other Titans as well and assert his
dominance again but which ones well we
will have to find out in 2 weeks
time now with that we have come to the
end of this video yeah if you like this
one then watch this other one as well
and do check out our channel for more
monster verse content we might have
things that you haven't seen before like
subscribe and we'll see you in the next
video take care fam